hello in this video we'll talk about
antibody dependent cell mediated
cytotoxicity or adcc response
adcc is a mechanism of cell mediated
immunity
imagine we are infected by
several pathogens like bacteria in that
case our body will produce antibodies to
neutralize these pathogens
and in case of adcc several cellular
mediators or effector cells actually
recognize one portion of this anti
antibody and thereby it engulfs the cell
which is coated by the antibody and this
is
cell mediated cytotoxicity because it
involves effector cell now the question
is what are the effector cells and
in which context adcc is really
important
so imagine we are infected by a virus
our body
would fight back by producing antibodies
against this virus and these antibodies
would potentially attenuate the virus or
disable the virus from entering other
cell types
and this is basically a humeral immune
response
so
in case of active virus it can interact
with a cell surface receptor and thereby
it gets its entry inside the cell but
the attenuated virus cannot enter
because it's blocked by the antibodies
so what will happen to these attenuated
virus
it turns out that there are several
effector cells which can recognize some
portion of the antibodies and it can
ultimately engulf the
attenuated virus and thereby destroying
it
but the question is what are these
effector cells so if we think about
viral infection these effector cells
could be
several cell types which has
fc receptor
cells like neutrophils nk cells
dendritic cells or macrophages all can
potentially act like an effector cell
because all of them has fc receptors on
them among them the most potent one is
the nk cells
similar kind of response happens against
bacteria or even helminth infection and
thereby the pathogens are eliminated
now let me tell you that antibody
dependent cell mediated cytotoxicity is
associated with type 2 hypersensitivity
reaction one example of that is
mismatched blood transfusion we know
there are several type of antigens in
our rbcs right and based on that we have
blood group a b a b or o imagine a
situation where a person with blood
group a has given blood to a person with
blood group b clearly this is a mismatch
blood transfusion now in person a
there would be anti-b antibody and there
would be a antigen on the rbc's surface
now in the recipient
who has blood group b has b antigen on
the rbc surface and anti a antibody
in the plasma
now in case of this transfusion the anti
b antibody which comes from the donor
would eventually bind on the b antigen
present in recipients rbc
then it would attract the attention from
other affected cells like macrophages or
natural killer cells which would
eventually lead to
destroy the rbc
so the rbc's could also be destroyed by
complement mediated lysis so this
particular video tells you that antibody
dependent cytotoxicity is a potential
mechanism underlying type 2
hypersensitivity responses
now principles of antibody dependent
cytotoxicity can be used for treatment
of cancer let me tell you how
now tumors have specific antigens on
their surface which are known as tumor
antigens now let's say a researcher has
generated a particular monoclonal
antibody against this
tumor antigens so obviously these
monoclonal antibodies would selectively
target the tumor cells and not the
normal cells because normal cells
doesn't have tumor antigens
and these are something which is very
specific for tumor cells
in that case
other effector cells like nk cells
can engulf the or destroy the tumor
cells by interacting via fc receptor and
thereby it can potentially reduce the
tumor volume and this is a topic of
ongoing research so what we learned in
this video in this video we learned what
is adccc response what are the cellular
players of adcc response adcc response
is a mechanism underlying type 2
hypersensitivity and lastly we
understand
that
cancer treatment can be done using the
principle of adcc especially in using
the nk cells to engulf or destroy the
tumor cells
so if you like this video give it a good
thumbs up you can support my channel in
patreon if you are an indian viewer you
can support me via vim upi
if you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can also find my courses
in unacademy which is india's biggest
learning platform
thanks for listening
and if you have any suggestion put it in
the comment see you in the next video
thank you